the way I went through was after I got
my equal numerators and let X equal two
that got rid of some terms for me I let
X equal zero back so C then B and then I
actually did exactly the same I compared
the x squared terms why is it the
comparing the x squared terms or rather
I should say comparing the degree terms
why is that such a wonder come up more
than once like I overlooked them too but
there's a reason why it's the easiest to
see right if you have a look at any
other term you're like ah gross you
could come from here and here I'm really
what you want is terms on this end what
terms on that in the closing time would
have been just as easy to find do you
notice that the constant term it could
only come from here and here yes but if
you're doing anything in-between
if for an example of the degree we say X
cubed right if you're doing the x
squared terms or the X terms you're
gonna have to be like wait which one is
it and almost certainly you will forget
okay okay serve let me show you this
question now I want to say to be
flashing lights this question in the
form that I afraid that to you nice
estimate not in the syllabus in fact it
okay I'm going to show you how to do it
anyway because just go through the
normal flow I've been doing and a
question very closely related true this
is successful is in the syllabus and
I'll show you that once we get to the
end okay yeah
yeah that's right that's correct
I'm exactly going to UM all I say for
sure once we get ceilings okay
um please remind me if I don't move up
now when you have a look at this okay
this is interesting beheading is
repeated the new factors and you can see
why right if I were to write this in the
normal form that we've seen before
I couldn't write it like this would you
be extraordinarily wonderful because if
I then write there are the three partial
fractions in credit comment I have
something over X minus 1 something over
X minus 2 and then there's something on
X minus 2 that's what you saw that
doesn't contribute anything what does
that make sense so you can see clearly
another approach is gonna be required so
how do I do this I'm gonna show you the
answer in a second the approach that I
need to take but first I want to justify
it a little bit okay
portal reunite to understand suppose I
were doing this not with polynomials but
just with numbers just through the
arithmetic okay if I said to you here is
a fraction and it came from some other
fractions right some other fractions
combined to create this one in exactly
the same way that some other fractions
combine to make this one does that make
sense how would you go about doing this
what kind of approaches could you take
think about what we've just done
okay so I'm gonna have to do some
division of this numerator obviously
just like here some comparison okay but
do you see before I get to that the
thing the mechanism that makes it works
is these denominators right I need to
factorize if it's in factorized form
it'll be better for me
the problem with this particular one is
you have a look at the factorization
what is the factorization how far can
you bring it down just now you don't go
as far as how would you bring that down
it's 2 cubed which is 8 times 3 and this
is a problem for us okay because when
you think about this and you think about
the original fractions that went into it
you can't necessarily know oh they must
have been like a haft yeah whatever to
turn that went in there or some number
of it's just there could be some number
and 4 or some number 8 all of those
could have gone in there and in fact
with this particular faction here's the
problem with just numerals there is a
vast number of different combinations as
opposed to here where there's a somewhat
unique one okay so I don't I don't know
whether it's a poor 1/8 or some mixture
of all of them I don't know from the
beginning everything is too jumbled up
once you if I started with this and
asked you to gather all this information
would be lost if all you had was a love
bomb right with polynomials the
information is not lost because we can
always spatter eyes down but with these
guys were kind of stuck so therefore
when I have a look at this question this
is really 1 over 2 1 over 2 squared 1
over 2 cubed I don't know which one
appears or how many off the same thing
happens here I don't know there whether
there will be a 1 over X minus 2 or 1
over X minus 2 all squared both of them
could appear so I have to account for
both of them
so here's the way I wonder I'm gonna let
this equal not two fractions
yes right all that would do is give me a
core drag denominator I need a cubic or
okay so to introduce that as well I need
a third fraction okay now this is the
equivalent of the 1/2 1/4 1/8 this is
the 1/4 turn right this could easily be
something that could you use this as
you'll see is when you set it up like
this it works in exactly the same way
I'm going to combine and where'd you
compare coefficients all that x equals
some kind of convenient value so this is
going to be equal to it let's have a
look here I want to get them all on this
denominator right so how many eight
times will I have it's gonna be X minus
2 all squared you agree with that if my
denominator is going to be this right
can you see if I cancel these have come
back to my original fraction it's been
what about B
X minus 1 and X minus 2 have to be added
on and then lastly the C term all I need
is the X minus 1 and then everything
will come out in the notch okay good if
I let the numerators be equal to each
other therefore x squared minus 2x
now I can choose some convenient values
what would you like me to choose now
that x equals one you can see what I do
x equals one because of the way this is
configured it's going to get rid of not
one but two terms this one in this one
both going to vanish do you see that
okay so that's linear called X equal 1
what are you get the left hand side and
that's equal to for this particular
value of C let's see so ironic so this
is going to be a times negative 1
squared this is going to become 0 and
this is going to become 0 you see that
she didn't disappear so it looks like
I've just got a on the right-hand side
what do I get on the left
are you happy that yep choose for me
another convenient Lu I just did one
right I'll go better I can beat it let X
equal 2 and you can see on my left hand
side I'm going to get 4 take away 4 plus
3 right which terms disappear on the
right hand side the eighth term
disappears the B term also disappears
and you just got left with C times to
take away 1 which is very convenient
won't always come out so nicely as
you've seen before so it looks like C is
just going to be equal to 3 ok I've got
a I've got to see what would you like me
to do to get the beat oh yeah so there's
no I've run out of convenient values to
put in because I've used up all my
factors so I'm going to compare x
squared coefficients what's the
coefficient of x squared on the left I'm
on it right what about on the right hand
side how many terms contribute to the x
squared
yeah you'll get an A here and a be there
x squared and you won't get any to see
ok so a plus B - I already know what a
is so that's the - okay happy times so
you can see here my conclusion is
therefore the original fraction can be
written in this form okay
a I'm gonna put a minus sign there and
three of these guys okay sir I said to
you yeah this this particular question
is a way that it was phrased you will
get assessed on
you have a look through this the
mathematics is more tired than any of
the other ones we did what you will get
asked is they'll provide you with this
line this is exactly what Nikki was
mentioned before they'll say I can't
keep through this can you prove it and
then can you do something with it
for instance now that I know what form
it looks like if I wanted to I could
integrate both sides could I not this
would be a log this will be a long
what's this guy gonna be yeah this is 3
X minus 2 to the power of negative 2 and
because the inside the derivative the
inside is just the constant you can just
do reverse chain rule on this okay so
the question a secondary part might leak
hints integrate that like that's a
fairly common way to ask the question so
they might show this to you and then if
you wanted to prove it well it's
actually very easy just add the
fractions together now which you could
do to confirm that that was the right
answer okay